[Music]
you're here to talk about targets
Application Platform just want to know
quickly like how many of you know about
Target Corporation yeah this is our team
over here you folks from retail how many
how many from the retail industry good
ok great so a little bit about Target
and then we will kind of move forward
right so we have about 1800 plus stores
in u.s. all in all 50 states we have
about 350 thousand team members our
headquarters is in Minneapolis we do
have locations in California and in
Bangalore in India about 30 million gas
visit our stores each week so our
e-commerce website received a
significant amount of traffic every
month it's kind of like the fourth most
visited retail website in the United
States but our website is just one part
of our digital strategy our flagship
mobile app allows you to easily purchase
products from your mobile phone
convenient features like map with
locations of the product that you are
looking for and Vallot which allows you
to combine our discounts such as
cartwheel and then kind of combine it
with red card discount and quickly check
out so we also have features like ship
and drive up and these do provide
convenient services for you to kind of
purchase stuff right out of your car or
delivers get stuff delivered straight to
your home another interesting thing that
we do is drive up
which gives you a way to order items
online and then we kind of notify you
once you once your items are ready to be
picked up you let us know what car
you're driving the color of your car you
drive to the store we use geofencing
somebody will walk out scan your app put
the items in your car and you can move
so that's kind of like a great service
that we provide but that's the marketing
side of it right so we are here to talk
about tech I didn't introduce myself but
Jim and I are talking here today I'll
let Jim introduce himself
and sure he'll go forward my name's Jim
Byers I run platform services inside of
Caron compute inside of infrastructure
and operations at Target our team
essentially is writing the software
that's powering tap target application
platform that we're here to talk to you
about J I work with Jim so my team is
responsible for the computer services
the underlying the VMS and the
kubernetes clusters that that run in our
data centers in stores and in Google
Cloud the the talk that we are going to
give today is the body of work that our
teams have done over the last year or so
so what we what we plan to do here is
kind of like share our journey that led
us to build an application development
platform so I'll kind of share the
landscape we had prior to building the
platform a target the problem we are
trying to solve and then we will talk a
bit about some of the principles that
form the basis of building this
application platform and then we will
share a little bit about the inner
workings of the platform and will give
you a walkthrough of how a developer
interacts with the platform and we will
finish off kind of sharing with you
folks how what's the current status of
it and our future plans so to speak
so how we got here I think many of you
who have been in the industry for a
while can probably relate to this you
know how it how it goes about is
application development teams need to
build and deploy like an app they reach
out generally to infrastructure teams
they make a specific request the infra
teams plays an order wait for the
servers to arrive we rack them and turn
it over to the development teams and
they kind of use it simple right I mean
but it's kind of complex right at the
same time we even did like service
enable the access to the computer right
but it only provided again like
incremental benefit so what are kind of
the problems that we faced just by
providing access to compute directly
infrastructure change fatigue right the
teams who got their pet servers ended up
spending a lot of time like patching
infrared teams like us and it up
spending a lot of time tracking
abandoned servers on new servers doing
like server upgrades for service enabled
platforms like OpenStack kubernetes we
still ended up like asking teams to do
the work right to make changes to
support the platform to do like upgrades
migrations things like that so
development team still ended up with
like a significant amount of
infrastructure work in there back in in
their backlog basically and this has
been like kind of disruptive for them so
that's one part now there is a other
part from a developer standpoint right
so the developer kind of faced like very
disparate experiences right they need to
deploy applications to our data centers
to our stores our distribution centers
to Google cloud deployment to OpenStack
in our data center is very different
than how do we deploy to a Google cloud
or to the average locations that run
kubernetes
these are all different that doubt so
the development team ended up using like
different deployment tools and they they
have to so build them they have to
maintain these tool chains and and this
is like work for the development teams
application development teams like that
support our distributed that work with
our distributed platforms like stores
sometimes end up spending like even 70%
of their development time like in
deploying workloads to these distributor
edge locations again plus on top of this
there is no standards in terms of like
how teams can implement logging
monitoring basic operational stuff
sometimes there are too many options
sometimes there are too less options so
it's kind of hard for developers to
figure out what's the right pattern to
use so we started off by removing
technical debt right so what's what's
technical debt we declared it as
anything right it can be obsolete
Hardware unused underused applications
anything that prevents you basically
from building capacity in a modern
technology so so we started kind of
working towards like removing technical
debt so we literally like removed
physical Hardware from our data centers
which are legacy we removed thousands of
like equipments from our stores old PDAs
servers and just kind we retired
hundreds of applications right so just
to how teams get rid off these legacy
backlog so that they can focus on
building new and how does it help right
so one it helps by us not having to pay
millions of dollars in terms of vendor
licensing cost and this also frees up
application development teams to start
building modern applications and we
started with that and we gave them
direct access to our service enabled
computes platforms and that doesn't help
it they will basically end up with like
a whole lot
or work when the lifecycle of these
compute services come up and this is
where tap comes into play so Jim will
talk about how we approach that problem
thanks Jay
so Jay sort of outlined sort of the
history as to why we decided we needed
to build tap I think you probably all
can relate pretty closely with a lot of
things he was talking about so before we
decided what or how to do what we're
going to do we decided sort of the why
if that makes sense and honestly even
before we started with the why we
decided with the who so pure of Jay and
ours guy by the name of Dan Woods came
up with this concept of someone that he
referred to as the midnight developer
and the midnight developer is someone
who's starting from nothing she may have
never had interacted with the platform
before maybe she started today and she's
trying to get something together for her
demo the next day if she can't build a
fully featured demo without having to
have like a meeting or a service now
request or whatever your ticketing
platform is like we've failed as a as a
as a team and disclaimer don't work at
midnight like to have a life
right so the six principles that we came
up with are as follows so the first ones
self service like I mentioned it's zero
meanings up and running and power the
teams to get their project off the
ground without needing to interface with
any of the platform teams no meetings
basically common patterns of usability
so teams will interact with the platform
offerings in a common way
so when Jay was talking about disparate
experiences like if you have to write
chef scripts to deploy things to stores
and you are using spinnaker deploy to
GCP if that's you know we're not having
a common experience discoverability team
should be able to quickly and easily
ascertain what the capabilities are that
available to them on the platform so
essentially similar to what the no
meetings it should be like not know Docs
but it should be fairly intuitive to
open up the page look at what you need
to do I need a load balancer click a
button not read for 30 minutes or try
and find some tribal knowledge no
searching wiki pages availability it's
got to be up all the time
we're not gonna have maintenance windows
and dev is prod
everything's an application tap uses tap
we bootstrapped app with itself that's a
big broad conversation if you'd like to
hear more about it how people talk to
you about it after
and then strong opinions loosely held so
that means that the decisions that we
made today for the underlying
implementations of the componentry of
the platform may not be the appropriate
decisions for the underlying componentry
of the platform tomorrow so we need to
build the platform in such a way that we
can swap things in and out
interchangeably and we've done that
quite a bit in the last year so what did
we build we built tap you already know
that it's the target application
platform and tap is this consistent
experience like we outlined in the
principles what tap is not is github
enterprise it is not our factory it it's
not spinnaker it is not kubernetes it
does not OpenStack it's none of these
things it's essentially the overlying
platform that obstructs you away from
these independent tools so that you have
got a consistent experience across all
of them it's like the glue code that we
wrote to do this right and we did this
by starting by saying like we're gonna
look at what's the fundamental
underlying sort of runtime components
that we need to have and obviously one
of those is computing so kubernetes is a
fantastic container scheduler it's also
a great platform but it's a fantastic
container scheduler so we started with
the idea of like let's figure out how we
can leverage the scheduling aspects of
kubernetes but open up so that we can
use other areas other pieces of the
runtime components other than kubernetes
so in other words what I'm saying is
we're not just dumping everything into
kubernetes so what we did was we wrote
shim layers in front of each deployment
of kubernetes so that we're deploying
through the shim so what that means
specifically is we decided to use the
kubernetes deployment spec for every
deployment when we deploy to a compute
provider and what that allows us to do
is to have multiple instance instances
of kubernetes that could be potentially
different versions they can be running
on obviously different compute and
ultimately that's all abstract it away
from the
we recently ran into the cooper name
kubernetes 1.6 vulnerability i'm sure
everybody is used to there were breaking
changes in the contract between 1/6 and
whatever we went to 114 that was work
for people and that goes back to what
Jay was saying before about how we don't
want them to have to worry about these
kinds of things the other really cool
thing that this allows us to do is to
present other compute providers with the
same deployment spec so you write your
app once and you can deploy it to
kubernetes you can deploy it
we started with OpenStack for our VM VM
provider which solved a different
problem whereas before we ran into some
issues with large installations of
compute services providers like
OpenStack with doing things like
upgrades infrastructure upgrades now we
can do our favorite tagline more of them
smaller so that if we want to take out
some compute provider for maintenance or
something like that all we have to do is
have teams redeploy we can take things
offline nobody even needs to know which
is pretty sweet and so we can do the
same thing with other computers rinse
repeat
how do we deploy to those computer
fighters we wrote a what we call this
platform intelligent it engine or PI
that implements the kubernetes
deployment spec also and then makes an
intelligent placement decision to one of
those compute providers now to be honest
the actual intelligence of the platform
intelligence engine right now is not
particularly intelligent we we taken
some of this some of the difference
backs like we have these other concepts
I'll touch on a little bit like pool
type or if you're a compliant workload
or if you want to be a VM or a container
runtime and then we make a decision and
some of the ways that we do that right
now is just by waiting or giving
preference to specific what we call pie
slices that's a computer fighter to say
hey deploy here a really crazy and great
story is Jay's team wrote something that
we call SG DM it stands for a server
group deployment manager and all it does
is it's a VM runtime dead simple runs
VMs really really well and we moved all
of almost all of all of our
non-compliant workloads that were
running on OpenStack over to SG DM and
none of
users even knew which is pretty rad so
that's that so that covers the compute
provider aspects the other areas
obviously if the platform is this it's
not just running CPU cycles right we've
got things like config and secrets load
balancing log metrics and potentially
things like an API layer API proxy today
we still watch to say we started with
console for config we've taken out
pieces of console as we've over the
course of our journey and replace them
with some homegrown pieces etc and our
users didn't know which is great we use
vault for secrets we're using Fabio for
load balancing when you deploy your
instance basically Auto registers with
the load balancer which is pretty sweet
and that this goes back to sort of that
principle of the fact that we might make
decisions today that tomorrow we might
want to change so I'm gonna do a walk
through but I want to cover some basic
sort of core concepts and terminology
that's gonna be somewhat probably
important hope try and go over this
quickly because maybe it's gonna be
rudimentary for one another or for
people sorry so an application is
essentially a project you start your
your prop your application inside of the
UI or through the API everything at app
is API first so you don't ever have to
interact with the API if you don't want
to you can use a CLI that we also have
it's pretty great application is
essentially the container for your your
code inside of an application there's a
concept of a cluster an application can
have many clusters clusters belong to an
environment we only have two there's
Devon prod clusters have a logical are
the logical organization of
infrastructure you can have one or many
deployments like I said and you'd so you
deploy to a cluster instances and server
groups so your docker container or your
VM is an instance you can have one too
many of them inside of a server group
that's your basically unit of deployment
one of the things that we do require
inside of every application is that
every instance has what an instance
health check so you can run any docker
container you want on the platform but
it has to have a health check and the
reason that we implemented that is so
that if your application is up and
healthy as determined by you then it
will register with a load balancer and
start taking traffic
currently we only take HTTP traffic but
that's in flight pretty quick for us to
be able do TCP also and then there's
this concept of stacks so as I said
before applications are globally
namespaced stacks are also globally
namespace such that you can have a so
red sky as an application it target you
can have a red sky you eighty you can
have a red sky performance you can have
a red sky red sky if you want to all in
production and so that allows you to do
wired different deployments of your
application together so that you don't
get interference if that's what you want
safer specifically for performance so
that that covers the sort of high-level
concepts I just wanted to say because
you're gonna see some of those in the U
is we weren't brave enough to actually
do a demo but I have video shots video
screen shots of of the app here and I'm
be happy to show anybody this later if
they're interested in I can get on VPN
all right bear with me cuz taking video
screenshots of stuff is a little bit
wonky ok
so shoot already went too fast so this
shows here that basically my screen as a
user of tap it shows all the teams that
I'm on inside of tap because you might
want to be able to allow other people to
deploy your application and besides just
yourself seems reasonable right I'm
gonna walk you through what we call a
QuickStart I'm gonna create an app on
tab so I'm gonna click that button I'm
gonna say I want to start a new project
or I could start with existing code if
you ever used a platform as a service
some of this should look familiar to you
but obviously it targets some of its
target specific so I'm gonna choose my
application name it's my next demo I
think yep and I'm just gonna make sure
that it's available if it is now this is
mine I'll get to I'll come back to this
but like essentially when it gets
deployed its my next demo dot dev target
comm or if I'm in prod it's my next demo
dot prod target accom that hit that you
go directly to the app or the stack of
your using stacks blossom ID is
essentially just like a configuration ID
it's like a metadata service at Target
that allows us to do things like
caught chargebacks or it's not charged
back sorry show back so we can show how
much specific apps are costing etc etc
or to be able to tie back to a
particular line of business and then the
team like I talked about before if I
wanna give access to other other people
to manage my application inside of tap I
can add them to my team then I'm gonna
add my contacting email and my
description and then I'm going to say
hey what good huh big organization do I
want and I'm gonna choose me then I'm
gonna say go and then I'm gonna decide
here's the four things that we support
so far so praxis is an internal target
you I react set of components it's more
or less how most front-end stuff is
written in target so I can QuickStart
practice app I can do a spring boot app
I can do a rat pack app or a rat pack
with groobie about 85 percent of the
target apps are spring boot we think so
I'm just gonna do that also it's long I
know how to do and and then I get to
decide between a container and a virtual
machine so like we said before it's not
specific to the actual compute provider
because we want to have the capability
being able to sort of decide what's the
best thing for today so maybe today it's
OpenStack but it's not now it's it's SG
DM so we decided to do virtual machine
so that we could make those decisions as
we're the ones that are supporting the
infrastructure and the same thing we
believe is true for the container for
containers probably kubernetes though so
I chose container and it's just telling
me what its gonna do now which is gonna
scaffold out some code and github it's
gonna create my drone config and it's
going to run my building drone so drones
our CI tool if you guys aren't familiar
with it and then it's going to deploy
create my cluster and deploy my and
deploy my code so I forgot that I had to
be signed in to drone when I made this
so I signed in to drone and then it did
it so you can see here that it actually
had already been working but I wasn't
signed in and it so I built built my
code so like I said this is a little bit
wonky give me a second there we go sorry
alright so after that this is just a
short screen that shows it essentially
that we in it we met the scaffolded code
in github it ran my drone job and it
created the cluster and then after that
it actually created the cluster but I
wanted to show what it's like for you to
create your own so this concept is the
concept of stacks so this goes back into
like if I wanted to have different
environments inside of my environment
because I wanted to test out different
lines of code here's my my next demo -
dev it's available i'm gonna click
continue and then these just some of the
config items that people can select from
so today we only allow to deploy it at
the data center we started some work on
being able to deploy it it to public
louder to GCP we yeah and then also
obviously you know as Jay mentioned our
goal is to be able to deploy workloads
also to stores and today's sorry to do
distribution centers there we go
so pool type is a something that we also
allow for you be able to sort of define
if you've got constraints with respect
to your runtime so if you are a Sox
application you would choose that you
wanted the Sox pool type we have some
special sort of stuff that we reserved
only to certain users at Target so like
there's a group that's doing work on GPU
we created a pie slice that was able to
deploy to some GPUs and they're able to
see that in here which is pretty slick
and then there's a proprietor type like
I chose earlier there's a container in
the EM runtime and then the region at
the end is we've got TTC and tter
the target data centers and then there's
also an option to choose H a I'll come
back to that because this is essentially
just like my app is running on port 8080
which is on that the load balancers
going to hit and then I get some choices
that are look very similar to kubernetes
with respect to how many Miller Coors
and how much memory I want this is the
health check I talked about so
you can implement your health check
however you want but you have to have
one so that we know that your app is up
and up and available because we don't
want the load balancer obviously to
route traffic to garbage instances that
are not working this is just basically
the configure that this is the
deployment strategy today we only need
support to red black or blue green
depending on if you are more akin to
Netflix and then and then Highlander so
deploy my instance group wait for it to
be healthy and then I'll start running
traffic to it or deploy it and then to
destroy the other one right away which
I'm embarrassed to say it look took me a
long time to realize why it was called
Highland Earth there can be only one so
a server group capacity is just how many
instances do I want to deploy you can
say one I don't think we have a limit I
know for sure that there's some people
that have like 80 actually died maybe
more than that
choose your choose the size of the
number of instances that you want then
deploy we do have plans in the future to
be able to do things with the platform
intelligence engine to say like hey
someone today might say hey man I'm
gonna get a I'm gonna get a million TPS
well that's generally never true and so
they might way over provision and we
could have the potential since every app
that's deployed is using the runtime
connector is automatically instrumented
with logs and metrics so we know the
health of everything as long as it's
running with the health tech endpoint
and it's using the runtime connector so
we would be able to do what I'm talking
about which is if it's taking two TPS
and running at point zero one percent
CPU utilization would probably would
scale them down in the future
so and then like I said before
everything is API first so you'll see
here that that's essentially the JSON of
what the API will look like next details
so now that I've deployed my cluster
it's up and running I'm just gonna go
and check and say hey here's my pipeline
we're using pieces of spinnaker onto the
covers to run
deployments for for tap for tap there's
a quite a bit of custom pieces that
we've taken out and rewritten ourselves
because they were more akin to our use
case I'll say so essentially that's the
your spinnaker pipe line create the
server group disable the old one and
create the new one here's the UI for
config and secrets
so for console for config and vault for
secrets you can enter your stuff in
right here and it'll get injected in
your application provided you've written
your code correctly and let's see this
is basically going back and being able
to edit those constraints I showed you
earlier if you want to do your
deployment it's not an uncommon thing
for us to find customers that deployed a
container run time and find out that
they're actually very compute intensive
workloads that they decide that it's
better for them to run on VMs that's
actually quite common and oh yeah so
inside my group of server groups there
would be if I had more than one instance
all the individual instance I can go
directly to my instance logs directly to
my health check endpoints so I clicked
on that that takes me to log specific
for that runtime sorry for that
container we there's health checks
specifically for that for that help
sorry for that instance and alright so
this is pretty slick and I'm the reason
I said before about the H a I was happy
to have caught one earlier but basically
what we see here is a sort of production
view of the platform intelligence engine
so on the bottom is a are a list of all
of the pie slices which if you remember
is the facade that sits in front of a
computer writer so if you you can kind
of infer what most of them are the first
one is is a k8 provider that's running
inside of our TTS data center and we've
got 1,300 instances in there you can see
that overall of all of tap we've got a
little over 20,000 running and I think
it comes right at 20 seconds you can
actually see in the pie slice activity
that a little spiral dealio actual
deployments that are going
which is kind of cool and right at 20
seconds you'll see though to happen and
it's an HJ deploy one to TTC and the
other one to TTC II if we scroll down
then you'll see sort of some of those
constraints like we talked about um just
about everything in here I think is well
known that's not true
most most everything is obviously
gen-pop hence Jen population but you've
got socks the socks a pool type running
an openstack you've got gen-pop running
on a VM this is that SV I was talking
about and there's a bunch of different
pie slices in here including I think the
I can't find it I don't remember I know
the GPU one is in here there's like four
GPUs it's not that cool
so that is PI and J's gonna talk now a
little bit about the status of tap and
sort of where we're at today thanks Jim
sure
can we switch our work to the likes oh
yeah that's fine so current status right
this was launched last year specifically
like April 1st to catch
so we exactly one year into building
building the platform and running it and
you can see the adoption curve it's just
kind of rocketed up right and this is
real right it's it's running production
workloads in target supporting our
business
this chart is like few weeks old and you
know the current one it's still still
the growth is like the same pace we now
have about 5,400 applications running i
we have about 20,000 instances four
deployments per minute that's that's
happening so if we think about it the
friction that we are removing from our
development teams right they are doing
like about 5,700 deployments per day
right and without like just by clicking
buttons this this is like
work they don't have to do so that's
that's actually advantage for us so
future plants so our vision is that tap
will be one-stop shop for all compute
and data needs for our developers so we
will accomplish this by abstracting the
computer and the data provider layers
away from the developers as Jim demoted
so they no longer have to worry about
you know which portion of kubernetes
they're running on whether they're
running on Google cloud or in our data
centers Jim also demoed and and sure
talked about fire earlier this compound
or the tab will become intelligent over
time and and with that intelligence we
will be able to make automatic workload
placements using tap basically
determining which is the best location
to run the workload we also have a great
ability to improve efficiency of our
compute platforms we can actually
understand the applications resource
usage and even if they are allocated
like a higher resource than what they
actually need the platform can actually
dial it down we also have of course in
our custom compute platform we have much
better ability to over provision we
actually see like about 70 to 80 percent
of physical compute utilization in our
custom compute platform which is kind of
great
so our plants Jim kind of touched on it
too
currently our focus is aren't getting
things running in data center we are
going to switch over to get this thing
working in Google Cloud and to our edge
locations in stores and distribution
centers we already have kubernetes
clusters running in our stores and
distribution centers the plan is to have
this platform that we build call
Unimatrix integrate that with tap so
that developers interact with tap and
that's the way they will deploy
workloads in target they're not going to
have any of those disparate experiences
as I mentioned earlier we can move
workloads around based on attributes
like availability response time the tab
we should be able to burst work load
into Google cloud if we need to or we
can automatically move workloads to our
edge if we need a better response time
or availability so basically we see tap
as like the one-stop shop for like our
developers to interact with
infrastructure so we are excited about
our journey and we believe tab gives our
developers the ability to focus on
delivering new feature functions for our
guests and like build productivity tools
for our team members and thanks to tap I
believe our application developers will
be able to do this in a much faster rate
than any of our competitors in our
industry thanks thanks
[Applause]
[Music]